wenn es nach einem der bekanntesten
astrophysiker der usa geht kanälen musk
den warp antrieb erfinden wie bitte
was es mit dieser geschichte auf sich
hat erfahrt ihr jetzt gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen niedergerissen ist eine art
amerikanischer harald lesch und erklärt
in seinen fernsehshows die weiten des
weltraums
es gibt wohl nur wenige amerikaner die
nicht kennen seine meinung hat also
einiges an gewicht und auch wer hier von
klicks und science fiction dürften schon
ein video von ihm in deutscher
übersetzung online stellen in dem es um
die prinzipien von wissenschaft ging
vielen dank nil der link ist hier unter
me und in der video beschreibung und
nils theissen hat nun bei twitter
angefragt ob ihnen musk multimillionär
und ceo der firma spacex nicht mal den
warp antrieb erfinden könnte er schrieb
wann hörst du auf deine zeit mit mars
raketen helfer luke zügen elektrischen
trucks und wir hören computern zu
vergeuden und entwickelst endlich den
warp antrieb orban trieb das thema
hatten wir hier schon im prinzip würde
eine solche technologie ähnlich wie ein
wurmloch funktionieren durch genügend
energie wird der raum vor dem raumschiff
gekrümmt wie ein blatt papier also
zusammengedrückt und hinter dem
raumschiff wieder auseinander gezogen
weil man den raum krümmt und sich nicht
im raum bewegt kann man sich schneller
als licht wort bewegen denn dazu ist der
raum in der lage unser universum dehnt
sich zum beispiel schneller aus als mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit auf diese art und
weise könnten gigantische strecken in
kürzester zeit zurückgelegt werden
das klingt seltsam da albert einstein
eigentlich die maxime aufgestellt hat
dass man eben sich nicht schneller als
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen kann
und das stimmt auch der warp antrieb
macht das raumschiff selbst nicht
schneller sondern verändert die strecke
den raum den man zurücklegen muss das
ist ein bisschen wie ein rollband am
flughafen man selber geht nicht
schneller als sonst aber da der boden
sich mit bewegt kommt man zügiger voran
ja und kanälen macht nun wirklich in
worb antrieb erfinden
seine antwort bei twitter ließ
jedenfalls nicht lange auf sich warten
er schrieb wenn wir eine stadt auf dem
mars bauen wird der transport von der
erde eine wirksame motivation
um etwas wie den warp antrieb zu
entwickeln damit könnte er recht haben
eine reise zum mars dauert derzeit wohl
einige monate
sobald es aber die ersten städte auf dem
mars gibt werden jede menge menschen
zwischen den beiden planeten hin und
herreisen für geschäftliche meetings für
familientreffen und für urlauber auf dem
roten planeten
je mehr reisen das geben wird desto
größer wird die motivation für
staatliche und private
forschungseinrichtungen seien an
verbesserten antrieben zu forschen die
uns die planetare reise erleichtern
werden masken space ex scheinen also
noch nicht am bob antrieb zu forschen
aber ihre versuche den mars zu besiedeln
könnten diese technologie in zukunft
wesentlich realistischer machen ehe
maske hat übrigens auch noch ganz andere
pläne mit dem mars er will ihn mit
atombomben bombardieren völlig irre mehr
darüber erfahrt ihr in diesem clip ihr
also anklicken von tim von oslo comics
tv news unbedingt draufklicken anschauen
und us comics tv abonnieren teams ziel
ist es dieses jahr noch 17.000 abos zu
erreichen vielleicht können wir im jahr
dabei helfen
ich würde da ja eher die 20.000
analysieren also wer unterstützt mich
dabei bis dann bleib dran